what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we're here to watch The
Last of Us episode thrust today that's
three interests combined and of course
joining me today a man who I love dearly
talk about last of us together all the
time Andrew Gordon how are you I'm doing
well thanks and love you too buddy thank
you give this man a follow ladies and
gentlemen it would mean the world right
now if you could leave a like leave a
like to show your support for the last
of us also subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction is up for the next episode
of this show as always full and threats
and watch as long as we sync up with
your own copyright Last of Us available
for a super sexy rejects that's our
patrons over at our patreon page of
course covers several things over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included and we launched a
website recently be easier for patrons
to navigate all of our posts that we
have over there as a reminder John and
Tara's reaction for this episode will go
up in just a couple of days they they
haven't played the game that's the
non-gamer reactions and then people have
been really enjoying those two the last
thing though you guys might notice in
most of the videos you'll probably see
me drinking something like this a g fuel
can because I reached out to G fuel a
while ago because I love their product
and I've always seen these YouTubers
constantly promoting g-fuel and I was
like what the heck I actually use your
stuff all the time can I work with you
and they said yes so yeah guys if you
want something that keeps you able to go
through the long hours of the day and
help teeth get sharp and focused and
energized and also not crash G fuel
thank you g fuel for working with them
while a proud customer
hey guys I'm going to show you a
reaction in just a second but I wanted
to pop in here real quick because as I
was prepping this video I I learned the
really sad and unfortunate news that any
wershing who plays Tess in The Last of
Us video game she passed away at the age
of 45 that is just way too young to go
but she's phenomenal in the video game
but she also has like a wide range of
other work throughout the years so
firstly I just want to say Annie thank
you for the Fantastic artistic
contribution that you have gifted us
with through all this time and to my
understanding she left behind a husband
and three boys right now there's a
GoFundMe that's been set up where all
contributions will go to her family so I
have put the GoFundMe in the description
box if you wish to donate yeah it's a
real unfortunate passing but thank you
Annie for everything that you gave us
and rest in peace and thoughts and
prayers of their family look I've been
thinking about what you're sorry I
wasn't gonna say I'm sorry nobody made
you a test take nobody made you go along
with this plan don't blame me for
something that isn't my fault
you're speaking truths right now
I love how smart she is good change yeah
it's interesting to add that on
he's like straight out of the game love
it I love this shot that reflection yeah
oh I didn't even notice that how'd you
get that scar on your head what is it
something lame like you fell down the
stairs or something
someone shot at me and missed see that's
cool
you get them
no I missed two it happens more often
than you think
shooting or like in general
in general
I mean back a minute I gotta grab some
stuff I stashed go grab supplies check
all the drawers check for notes check
for tools no way
you ever played this one Mortal Kombat
the second one there's just one
character named she has monster teeth
and then she swallows you whole and
bursts out your bones I could never
figure out how to do that I was similar
to the game but it was a different game
Angel knives I believe it was called is
there anything bad in here just you
getting funnier
they're back back and forth sounds so
much longer
yeah definitely wouldn't go down there
yes seriously
Ally because Andrew calls her belly
lockers
oh no is that a stalker
oh it's trapped okay yeah you didn't
notice that still makes it scary
I close it's like wow so close to
clicker stage
just
trying to see if she has capable of
killing it
what you doing homie
[Music]
oh that's pretty cool
whoa yeah that would be the first one
she ever killed right on the show yeah I
believe so
there we go ready in protective mode I
love it kicked over my ass
after this thing makes it mostly useless
you're just gonna leave it there
[Music]
hahaha
you're way too heavy for you to just
carry around man yeah he's gonna say
that thing weighs more than you
you flying one of those whoa it shoved
into a middle C pay 12 bucks for a
sandwich
there's something we take for granted
even start
if you have to get bit to be infected
then who bit the first person he's like
go look up Wikipedia I thought you went
to school address School teachers how to
shitty government failed to prevent a
pandemic
oh
so they got into the food supply
probably a basic ingredient like flour
or sugar yep there were certain brands
of food that were sold everywhere all
across the country bread cereal pancake
mix
thank you that's right so the tainted
food all hits the store shelves around
the same time Thursday evening
it got worse and they're really giving
us the whole backstory here nice
Mercedes the monkeys
a monkey references the game
whoa Judgment Day told you you were
going to a qz and you were if there was
room if there wasn't
[Music]
prevention dead people can't be infected
oh wow
ah so our prologue is mid lug yeah
[Music]
is that bill possibly looks like Nick
Offerman not today you knew World Order
Jack boot
yeah I'd say that's him
you can see hints I love it
damn so bill was like always prepared
for a scenario like this
The Masks
I know we don't get spores we at least
get a mask scene
oh this is so cool we're getting this
entire backstory
it's gonna give us a sense of who bill
is before we actually see them meet him
so it's good
freedom
[Laughter]
someone who Embraces the apocalypse
that's funny
resourceful bill
Nick Offerman is perfect for this camera
he is perfect
such a cool Montage he's a guy who
Embraces his Solitude he's been waiting
for this day forever always like this is
Haven
yeah the wrench he just looks straight
up just like Bill I love it
there's an empty seat there though bill
oh
he's got traps
[Music]
yes
that reaction I know
let me just have another by mistake oh
he is perfect oh yeah he captures Bill
perfectly for sure
ah
this is great you barely get to explore
bill in the game yeah you really don't
really feels like this really feels like
it's Canon to what's in the game yeah
Jurassic Park at his place yeah
but not infected ah are you armed is
this is how they met no why did you take
that long to answer I thought about
lying for some reason but
I'm just trying to get to Boston
it hurt
s to Bruce
yeah all those flies
letting down the ladder
you just had that ladder right nearby
green means go I haven't eaten in two
days I'm letting you go so go
[Laughter]
first my name's Frank oh yeah nice to
meet you Frank if I feed you then every
bum you talk to about it is gonna show
up here looking for a free lunch and
this is not an Arby's
Harvest didn't have free lunch was a
restaurant
[Laughter]
it's got to be a romance between them
yeah for sure yeah it has to be it is it
was even hinted at it it was hinted at
it was never explicit
let's take a peek in there
nice to see the softer nicer side of
Bill yeah I mean he's been lonely for
four years
[Music]
you know they're all wearing flannel I'm
gonna put my flannel
he was so happy isn't that a real
home-cooked meal in years he's like this
is better than Arby's
what the [__]
[Music]
the Elegance
I got you a little nervous huh
and I want you to have some more wine
oh hair back so I guess I'll be going
then
oh but first I've been staring at this
the whole time is it antique you know
how much these are worth currently
nothing
that was such a perfect delivery he's
not yours my mother's could do that
this is you it's like the game he
doesn't like anyone touching his stuff
I take things
[Music]
then I'll leave I like him a lot love
will abide
make Offerman you're perfect take things
and strive but there's no one at my
app lyrics
[Music]
it's beautiful it was so who's the girl
um
there is no girl
oh
wow this is beautiful what's your name
Bill
oh
go take a shower bill
wow
this is heaven felt love in so long
if you really feel that
[Music]
it's really beautiful
how dare the camera pan up
laughs
the simple things
okay okay
I get like the child decides of Bill
here oh [__] you come on ah you live in
a psycho bunker where 911 was an inside
job and and the government are all Nazis
the government are all Nazis
paying attention to things it's how we
show love fixing up some of the shops
whoa not the stupid ones just the the
wine shop in the furniture store
wow it's just so particular about how
everything is the boutique
are we hosting formal Garden parties now
no
[Laughter]
but we are gonna have friends and we
will invite them to visit
there are no friends to be had I've
actually been talking to a nice woman on
the radio
hmm
you want oh well this really is just
oh yeah it makes sense
oh that is neat what can I just say on
gun aside which I get I
smart way to bring her back I mean I
said I want to thank you he's gotta say
another gun hold
you know what
let's go inside Tess I want to show you
something oh bills and I like that right
Frank songs
oh we get some Bill Joel moment yeah I
love it
[Laughter]
let's go Maya
mine
brought strangers into our situation I
wouldn't be happy either because
cinnamon Tess never had a title stuff we
have an accusing that you don't have
here we can't help each other and get
that gun out of my face
it's smuggling that fence got a year on
it tops
I can get you 10 spools of high tensile
aluminum last you the rest of your life
lives
this is awesome that's such a good
expansion you should use codes for the
radio because he was listening oh that's
a good idea
there will be Raiders they'll beat that
fence in your trip wires they'll come at
night quiet and armed we'll be fine
history yeah I didn't I guess I never
registered how long Tess and Joel had
been together damn
is when the game started just one more
loop around
I got something to show you
not that the first two weeks are always
the hardest bill
oh no way oh I traded Joel and test one
of your guns for a packet of seeds
which gun
shotgun a little one huh
[Music]
foreign
love that laugh he gave
wow
[Music]
I'm sorry getting older faster than you
I like you older I was never afraid
before you showed up
oh
it's so touching
those fences aren't gonna hold up it's
like Joel said
oh
he feels right it's like the Terminator
[Music]
foreign
I gotcha I just gotta patch it up he'll
be fine
[Music]
a lot of imagery kind of evoked the
Sarah fights we have copies of all the
keys good
yeah cool
Jewel
you're here you know
I was never afraid but was afraid to
lose Frank
IE in a wheelchair
what's wrong with Ryan really two good
job of Aging them
such good makeup that's crazy guess he
got older faster than
build it might have a disease or a
sickness too oh well wow yeah it looks
awesome too
oh
the only friends they made were Joel and
Tess which of their friends do you need
besides those two yeah did you take your
pills
oh yes they didn't go to any pharmacy
they want in town I guess or medicine
from the qz
big Roundy
I love how much time we're getting to
spend with these characters
oh
of him yeah yeah
I guess I just wasn't expecting that's
such a touching story
I knew we were going to get their
backstory she didn't know it was going
to be this emotion on this long it's
great I don't want you fall asleep in
the chair I'm not fighting about it back
in bed I promise you I'm gonna stay up
why because this is my last day
I've made up my mind
spell
um
every day was a wonderful gift from
God's speech I have had a lot of bad
days
but I've had more good days with you
than with anyone else just give me one
more good day
starting now make me some toast
you'll wear what I ask we'll get married
oh
now we fall asleep in your arms
so we're just not going into my mouth
you love me
yes then love me the way I want you to
I always imagined it would end like so
uh angrily between them
they were gonna have Joel and Tess as
witnesses as just for them
[Music]
the first meal he ever made yeah
oh
you gotta get him the wine too
he turned it yep
[Music]
uh
damn the show is so touchy yeah
this is not going right in my mouth
interesting
why are there already pills in the
bottle enough to kill a horse this isn't
the tragic suit at the end of the play
and you were my purpose
oh
I do not support this
oh it should be furious
hair at the finish line
but from an objective point of view it's
incredibly romantic
[Laughter]
take me to bed
sounds like music from the game
[Music]
foreign
killed it oh they're phenomenal
incredible they got great chemistry and
like they played the Aging wonderfully
[Music]
I love the inclusion of this music from
the game
so poetic
wow
um
that's incredible
flowers not being tended to make sense
it's from Bill
to whomever or probably Joel
[Laughter]
so clever so they're dead
wow I'm guessing you found this Jewel
because anyone else would have been
electrocuted or blown up by one of my
traps
foreign
take anything you need the bunker code
is the same as the gate code but in
Reverse such a clue from a letter uh
yeah yeah like a combination for the
lock I used to hate the world and I was
happy when everyone died there was one
person worth saving
that's what I did
I saved him
then I protected him you know what to do
Joel that's why men like you and me are
here we have a job to do and God help
any mother you stand in our way
I leave you all of my weapons and
equipment
use them to keep
yes
oh boy
[Music]
the second one bill crumbled the note oh
man let it out
[Music]
here to get them in the game huh
he is
such a shell of his former self he can't
even like cry over test I have a brother
out in Wyoming he's in some kind of
trouble and I'm heading up there to find
him
he used to be a firefly my guess is he
knows where some of them are out there
maybe they can get you to wherever this
lab is this Firefly just like Troy yeah
Troy Baker people I'm taking you with me
there's some rules you gotta follow
rule one you don't bring up tests ever
ah just like the game matter of fact we
can just keep our histories to ourselves
rule two we don't tell anyone about your
condition
yeah you see that bite mark they won't
think it through they'll just shoot you
that's true you do what I say when I say
it yep we clear it's
repeat it
say goes what you say goes straight at
the game I love it show it now
let me grab what we can you know you
skip over so many different levels and
they change so much especially regarding
the bill yeah it does not bother me yeah
it is so effective what they've done
instead I'm definitely well we'll talk
about it afterwards
dude no
there's so many options there's a wall
of them I'm right there with you
seriously let her have one there's even
the small ones there take a handgun
during a pandemic you gotta have toilet
paper I'm taking a shower
your shower
oh he gets flashes of Sarah yeah
oh her outfit look at that man yeah
sneak it Ellie
usually see her sneak it hold on you
look pretty
it's like I saw in a movie there were
Keys when you open the visor
it's your first time in a car it's like
a spaceship
yeah
love it she built such a good reference
yeah she's like what's that
this is so good
[Laughter]
might be the first person to say so cool
to a seat belt laying her right up front
Star-Lord put it back Ellie
[Music]
is
he just smile
he's regaining his Humanity
I love this episode oh it's so good
this to me is like this is last of us
you know
oh the shot of the window yeah
we won't spoil that but yeah
yeah that's amazing
oh boy
this did not feel like an hour and 15
minutes that's crazy yeah this show is
so well paced oh yeah oh my goodness
that works for me on every level yeah
every level with my eyes were just kind
of watering up like every 10 minutes of
that [__] uh yeah they it
I'd be very curious to hear the
conversation surrounding this one but
all we can do is talk from our hearts
here and yeah I mean like knowing the
game it it definitely
there's so much different right yeah way
different I mean way different yeah like
you and it sets up as as fans of the
game it's an interesting viewing
experience because like you're like all
right well
so what happens like uh the briefest
version that we could tell you in the
game is like they're looking for the
battery and then running into traps and
stuff and Bill is just like a hardened
[__] he is just the biggest [__]
in the world and but they need to go
through like all kinds like this there's
all like sneaking in when they sneak
into a not school and that they do go to
school
at some point they go through a school
yes but they have to like go through all
this crazy hoops and stuff and running
over it's it's it's it's gnarly fun
gameplay and everything and Bill's
awesome and Bill and Ellie do not get
along oh that's my favorite part and
that's probably if as a gamer fan I'm
like that's probably the one part of it
I'm like oh I would have loved to have
seen Ellie in bed yeah and and then
eventually they come across um you hear
there's like a falling out with him and
Frank and then they come across and
they're looking for a battery they run
into a house and and um they see that
Frank has hung up yeah yeah and so
Frank's already daddy you see Bill get
him
what are you talking about
um yeah so you see Frank's uh dead so
you never meet Frank in the game and
they allude to a history that there was
possibly something more to them than
just you know buddies uh but it was very
like Macho uh the way how uh Bill comes
across right and so imagine what you saw
Bill like at the if you haven't played
the game where you saw Bill like at the
beginning of this episode and he's like
a a more senile
uh more uh rageful version of that more
emotionally resistant version of that
just like an older version so watching
this I was like okay well I'm expecting
them to when it does like the three-year
jump uh like all right now we're
watching when things started uh falling
apart for them basically yes and I you
know you do set up an expectation
knowing the game that they will
they'll have a falling out he's probably
going to leave and and then you know
maybe Bill's going to morph into that
like bitter old man yes
and then after and after a while I'm
like I don't think it's going down that
path you know like I don't think they're
gonna do that and and even with the
drink I was like okay maybe Frank picked
up on that and switched the bottles
around or something like I kept
expecting Bill to to live still because
I'm like there's still so much with Bill
and and the battery and Morgan went on a
mission and everything and they didn't
do that and yet it didn't leave me upset
it didn't leave me angry or like why did
you rob us of that I can imagine I have
no idea obviously I have no idea what
people think of this episode yet
um but I can imagine that there will be
a camp that is really bummed out by that
and for me I found myself like no this
is I thought what they decided to do for
this show and this narrative it made it
more emotional and poignant and gave
Bill a thorough character Arc
and even when you land on the letter uh
by the end which you know like in the
game dead but dead people are always
leaving letters and so the combination
yeah in the game yeah
um yeah so yeah the the having the but I
like that when you finally get this
letter it's it's a very like emotional
moment
and and uh I I just thought it was
it was like this beautiful story of this
couple in the in the apocalypse like I I
wanted to I've had a short story of mine
that kind of was like the last five
minutes of their story a short film in
mind it was like a zombie story so
watching it take place and he never got
infected but how they just grew old
together and watching a man
watching bill this man change over time
into a person who learned to let people
in and learn to care and even leaving a
letter for like Joel at the end that was
so
that was so open and welcoming and
supportive and you could have whatever
you want was like I I think this is
perfect for the story they're choosing
to tell and how it motivates
um how it motivates Joel to you know
when he's reading the letter like okay I
gotta apply whatever Bill learned and I
gotta adopt this for Ellie right now
absolutely so yeah like they do they
skip over a bunch do they completely
change and eliminate a bunch oh yeah
they do but emotionally
to me that's that's what makes has made
this game so resonant it's not so much
like clickers and all that is like it's
really fun you know the gameplay isn't
all that like of course that's a big
part of the game but what's made it so
strong this the the game experience is
this
this heart this uh this sadness yet this
Bittersweet and melancholic Expressions
uh that's what has made the the last of
a story so beautiful and why it's
resonated for so long so while I miss
while I was sure I can miss like
watching gameplay stuff come to life I
think they replaced it with stuff that
is so much more powerful for this
live-action visual medium and I I know I
went off on a tangent there sorry Andrew
all right well I I got so much to say
now no but no no you I I agree with a
lot of what you said absolutely look
there's there might be some Gamers and
look I'd say like from a gamer
perspective there was definitely a
subversion of expectations for sure in
this episode like when you see like the
the three years later and you see them
start arguing like ah here it comes the
the the the the destruction of their
relationship and what happens because
again really quickly to like Greg
alluded to in the game basically what
happened is uh bill is so set in his
ways he's so like you know he just he's
like basically a homer doesn't want to
leave doesn't want to do anything and
Frank wants to explore and do other
things and that's kind of why he leaves
him and so that's a big part of the
falling out of the relationship and he
gets infected and that's why he hangs
himself so you know the we start to see
a little bit of that but again we get
that subversion of expectations but it
didn't bother the only thing that uh
again was I wouldn't say bothered I just
I know I use this word a lot uh but I
was just saddened by that we didn't get
to see Bill and Ellie but you know what
I get that in the game so it's more of
like a wish yeah exactly but again I get
that in the game so it's not that in the
world but because it's so again like
I've said in the first two episodes I
don't mind if you make changes as long
as it's done in a satisfying way and it
moves the plot forward in an interesting
way and I thought they did that really
well in this episode like the chemistry
between Nick Offerman and I apologize
for not knowing the actor's name who
plays Frank they're phenomenal together
like that are incredible like watching
that whole thing and I love the way too
like in the first two episodes how we
watched uh the prologue at the beginning
just explaining you know how the
quadriceps disease you know kind of uh
just giving the backstory that which was
done brilliantly I love I I call it like
uh uh is it Murray Bartlett is that his
name right uh yep yeah Murray Bartlett
uh him and Nick Hoffman they were great
together but I know we talked about in
the first two episodes the prologues
which again explain the cordyceps uh
infection the backstory fantastic and we
get the mid log if you will hear in this
episode which again I love linear
storytelling when it's done right and in
this episode it was done beautifully and
I love watching that relationship and
even though again it's totally different
from the game when I replay the game now
I'm gonna have this whole backstory of
Frank and again even though there's some
changes here and there I'm gonna have a
backstory of the relationship now of
like how they met and the and the bond
that they formed with each other and I I
really love to you you mentioned it at
the beginning like we did get to see
that hardened bill at the beginning like
you know just how we how like he's very
untrustworthy he doesn't want anyone
touching his stuff like don't touch the
piano don't touch them that's my that's
Bill like for for people who've never
played the game that's bill right there
do it t i mean not as heightened as you
would say as he as he gets in the game
not as easy
and we've got to give props to W Earl
Brown in the game he's awesome and the
game I love him as as Bill in the game
um but Nick Offerman freaking nailed in
this episode it was so again I just I
love the emotional balance that these
two brought uh with each other him and
Murray Bartlett they were just so good
together I mean I was so emotionally
invested but I love the they chose to do
this whole the the whole montage of
spending time with these characters like
if you would have told me before this
episode there's gonna be barely any
infected in this episode there's gonna
be barely any action in this episode
it's going to be more of a bill and
Frank Centric episode I'm like
curious to see how that's going to play
out I don't know if that's going to work
but seeing the way it was executed I
mean was flawlessly done and also we'd
be remiss to mention too I love the
stuff at the beginning the character
moments we got with Ellie and Joel yeah
that was great I love how it's bookended
by Ellie and Joel like the beginning
you're with them and then at the very
end you get this experience and
yeah when they checked back in I'm like
I I I really you know I know I've been
loving the show
but this was the first episode out of
the three that was
so much more different than the game
yeah not not emotionally not
thematically
um story-wise but yeah but story-wise
and seeing like a whole bunch you just
don't get in the game it seemed just so
like most of this is not in the game
right yeah and and then when you do
check back when that Ellie and Joel I I
like that's when I was like I know I
love I I love this show like it really
hit me in like a in a very different way
of yeah this is something truly special
and I also really love that they were
able to include tests back into it as
well like just showing that yeah I
forgot all about that but no just
kidding test back getting pick up on her
Tessie oh that was so good because I'm
like wait a minute does this actress
look like how she does it in 2023 or
2013. yeah not for sure that was great
and that was I mean I I love that they
had that that communication uh between
Frank and tessen it makes sense like for
even though we live in a post-apop or
they live in rather they live in a
post-apocalypse optic World Frank wants
to have a semblance of of normalcy you
know because they do live in a house
that where they do feel a little bit
normal but it's still a post-apocalyptic
world so hey let's let's have some
friends over let's let's feel a little
bit normal in this crazy psychotic
post-apocalyptic world I love that that
was a really good touch and we did get
alluded to that in in the video game
again obviously for those of you who've
played the game you already know this
but for those of you who don't Bill and
and Joel they know each other they
smuggled together they they work
together and test as well so it's nice
to actually see that history format a
little bit and again now you have a
little bit of that history formed out on
television for you when you didn't end
the game so again stuff that gets
expanded upon just really smart decision
making I mean I I love his show so but
it's so good yeah this was in some ways
you know it there's a there's an element
of of it that because it just hit me I
know because that's the thing is you
know when you like test dot it
I'm so I'm so used to like I've seen
Sarah die so many times in the video
game that I got my eyes I like yeah sure
I get like emotional watching it but I'm
not like
wow I am taking it back or like test
dying I'm just it's like I'm like oh wow
they're really doing this I'm really
feeling this and and like oh look at the
change oh my god look I'm so I'm like
absorbed in a lot of different thoughts
because I know the game so well uh but
this was such a different experience and
and I and I and I was like taken aback
when I was like oh Bill's gonna die
before he even meets Ellie yeah that's
surprising because he doesn't even die
in the game no yeah he doesn't yeah no
it's interesting and it was it was it
was an interesting choice and I'm I'm
just I am I am in awe of of the
experience of this particular episode
brought that it it shined A different
light and I I I'm I'm very curious to
see if if this episode does get like a
significant amount of backlash for such
a drastic change and I like but I I I'm
telling you someone who's played that
game
um and really remembers the bill the
experiences with Bill and and the back
and forth with Joel and Ellie especially
uh this did not bother me whatsoever we
do miss out on some good game levels I
thought we're pretty awesome there's
some scary stuff yeah yeah for sure but
it's fun when you're teamed up with with
uh with him yeah and it was so poetic
too seeing the whole Romeo and Juliet
suicide at the end I mean Sopo I can too
I love the uh just just a little
reference to from the game where uh Joel
crumples up the note that's basically
when when uh uh Bill found the note that
Joel gave him that said Frank uh wrote
wrote a note very similar to how uh what
build in there and it was very similar
and then Bill crumpled up the note and
said the f word Fu Frank and uh yeah it
was just it was a nice little touch
there were some so many awesome touches
and then they included some really cool
moments of music from Gustavo
santaolia I hope I said that right this
time guys uh but I love the spaceship
line oh yes yes we we flipped out over
the yeah we won't we won't go into that
people we don't want to spoil because
we've been accused of spoiling a lot
already
most of the second game they're flying
in a spaceship yes all right Greg
spoiled it they go to Mars in Jupiter
and Nexus and when they get different
across and when they get to Mars they
meet Doug Quade Arnold Schwarzenegger's
character from Total I'm in control of
these edits whatever I we I only keep
the things that it's like if we're
saying something that's gonna happen it
you know like that's only because it
happens and yeah
we're gonna talk about things that
happen in the future We're Not Gonna
spoil things for you guys who have not
played the video games don't worry like
we wouldn't do that to you only Greg but
no and uh yeah this was a great episode
but someone might be like they got
excited at this I didn't even play the
games I'm like well what is what is us
getting excited to tell you yeah yeah I
know for sure but I mean yeah okay
what information do you have to go off
you've got excited spoiled it they go
sipping around fighting you again it's
going to Star Wars what's going on but
to your point I I really am curious what
from the game because I know from the
non-casual fan I know this episode is is
gonna be very like is gonna fare well
for sure yeah I am curious from the
gamer's perspective because you and I
are hardcore fans of this as you all
know and we really enjoyed this episode
and didn't mind the changes yeah I was a
little bit sad and then we I because I I
love me some Bill and Ellie I got to
tell you if you have not played the
games just go watch the cutscenes of
Bill and Ellie that is damn entertaining
to watch they're damn good W Earl Brown
and Ashley Johnson have some damn good
lines together in the chemistry together
but again the way it's done here I get
it I get why they made the changes and
it didn't bother me and I still have
that version of the game so it it it is
what it is you know what would it have
been cool if they did that for sure but
with what we got here without the
quality of of what we got here with the
relationship of these two and how damn
emotionally invested I was it it didn't
bother me like I If you would have told
me this before the episode and I hadn't
seen a thing I would have said what yeah
but after having viewed it and in the
immersive incredible experience we just
got it doesn't bother me as much but I'm
curious to see what other game what
other you know hardcore Gamers that love
this uh that love the video game think
I'm I'm really curious I mean I think
that when it comes to
this this particular tale that they told
it felt like they told a romance or like
a romance during the apocalypse and
and when when they first kissed and and
you see like they're both crying like
that's the first moment where I was like
wow this is really affecting me because
these are like too bad it's like
thinking back on it I'm already getting
like I'm getting emotional again yeah
because
um they're they're such they're so
lonely like you and that's the quality
that I was capturing is this this
Lonesome experience and and I loved
seeing how Bill first took such joy in
the isolation like this is everything I
wanted I hate people and now I gotta
have this all to myself but then you see
over time it does grow weary and he
grows he grows solemn yeah he and then
when they find each other you know good
thing Frank's gaydar was activated
and when they kiss and then the way
they're connecting each other like they
found intimacy and you know they found
something that could be special and they
could survive together and to find love
in a situation where finding love seems
impossible right like even for Tess and
Joel like it's interesting to juxtapose
them together because I didn't really
register how many years yeah like oh wow
look they didn't even have gray hair
when they first knew each other and and
then Joel's so hardened and so afraid of
connection yeah which understandably so
but he's so afraid and so like so
opposed to it that nothing can even
bring him to tears about Tess yeah and
I'm like but damn you guys have been
like together for a long time and he
can't even say to like they couldn't
even establish a title between each
other like that's too much for them and
I like that Nuance between he couldn't
even say that's my girlfriend he doesn't
can't even call her that you know yeah
he didn't really give it a uh like a
position yeah label yeah but we're not
Facebook officials so I can't say yeah
yeah but we're exclusive yeah exactly no
but what I what else I loved about Bill
in this episode as well is he it you
know it wasn't just a character Arc it
was an emotional Arc as well and those
are my favorite kind of arcs when you
can combine the two because that's where
you get something really powerful and
Nick Offerman I
damn that was it did it's perfect yeah
no when I heard Nick Offerman was coming
I was like I could see him as Bill I
could see him as Bill and then we saw
the trailer I was like okay he looks
like Bill he looks like that that's not
gonna hurt Nick Offerman I was like
perfect yeah that was the one that was
the first one I heard was like perfect I
didn't say perfect but I said I I could
see him I could see him as Bill I can
see him as Bill but then when we saw the
trailer in the first letter okay it
looks like Bill I mean I haven't heard
any Lineback he looks like Bill then
when I watched this episode like all
right he's built yeah he's built well
the one they had to really sell you on
too was Frank yeah because I mean
they're both new characters uh you know
gamer non-gamer uh if you're not if he
didn't play the game it's it's like the
brand new he's brand both are brand new
characters but like for gamer fans
especially I was like all right let's
get to know Frank and I I liked how
I do love that they actually really
heavily lean into the romance between
them and they found ways of finding
keeping it very masculine but keeping it
also soft at the right times you know
what I mean
not to say that masculinity could not
Encompass being soft you know uh so it
was they found like wonderful nuance and
ways to complement each other and you
see why they were a perfect match yeah
why they were a good Yin and Yang
absolutely and also too last thing I
want to mention I love that we got to
see Ellie get her first infection kill
uh in terms of uh on I believe it was a
stalker that we saw uh stalker I believe
it was a stalker like a fully formed one
yet what stage is stalker again stalker
stage two
okay Runner stalker Clicker
uh so there's Runner Runners stalker
clicker shambler if you're in uh is that
spoiler you can edit that
um uh and then the b word we won't say
and then there's the r k word we won't
say sorry I don't know how to not
spoiled this
I thought what were the
whatever the one in the in the game when
they which game are we talking in the
first game when they're coming they may
change it but when it's like in the
hotel underground trying to turn on like
the other I think he's trying to turn
the elevator or something not the
elevator he's trying to turn something
on Joel it's those are stalkers
but like you see how in here
this like I can tell they're stalkers by
what I call what I call by the Mohawk
yeah when one eye is blind like that
that means they're close to clicker
stage that's a stalker okay I guess I've
never noticed with the stalkers that
their eye yeah that they have one normal
functioning eye I think both games I
don't think I've ever noticed yeah for
sure um
you're trying to get a good look of this
stuff he was playing Silent Hill he
wasn't playing I'm not taking in the
designs he's playing Resident Evils I'm
so focused on Surviving in the moment
that I'm not taking into designs
yeah I think anything you just taught me
I think I think I just realized I've
never taken in the designs of the
creatures because I'm always like just
kill them hey Paul from heavy spoilers
you're not the only one who can educate
see buddy yeah man but you are great I
do enjoy your channel dude
um
yeah okay guys uh this is this episode
was so good oh it was amazing this show
is so good and you see like um
the the one that's more fresh in my mind
is lots of us too because it's the one
I'm more recently played but like one
thing that I I mentioned this when I
think we were this is when the reaction
with the Paul's video have you suppose
this video was when you break
perspective and you see that when you
see Ellie snatch the gun like that
happens in the game but you don't see
that happen alrighty guys well thanks
for being here what did you think about
this episode of The Last of Us thanks to
G feel for sponsoring this video
and also
um yeah leave a like subscribe keep
looking for John Tara's reaction coming
later this week
[Music]